hace algunos vídeos estábamos en una
situación de comprar fruta o de comprar
chocolate y lo que queríamos era
maximizar la utilidad para esto teníamos
una tabla de utilidad marginal y
entonces al tener 50 pesos podíamos ir
gastando los poco a poco viendo nuestra
tabla de utilidad marginal para ver qué
era lo que nos convenía más para
maximizar hasta el final pues la
utilidad total entonces como le hacíamos
los primeros 10 pesos veíamos en que
convenía gastar los más entonces veíamos
la utilidad marginal por precio y
entonces convenía primero comprar un
chocolate porque nos daba una utilidad
marginal por precio de 10 comparado con
una utilidad marginal por precios de 6
de la fruta de modo similar comprábamos
el segundo y tercer chocolates entonces
ahí ya teníamos 3 chocolates pero a
partir de ahí la utilidad marginal
bajaba y ya nos convenía a comprar fruta
con esto acabamos comprando 3 chocolates
y dos medios kilos de fruta o sea un
kilo de fruta bueno la idea de este
vídeo es ver qué sucede si cambia el
precio del chocolate va si cambia el
precio del chocolate entonces esto va a
modificarla
y marginal por precio y entonces pues
posiblemente cambia la cantidad de
chocolates que se vendan verdad o sea
ahorita con un precio de 10 se venden 3
chocolates entonces qué sucede si cambia
este precio vamos a ver eso si logramos
ver eso entonces vamos a poder pues
entender un poco más la intuición detrás
de la curva de demanda porque justo a la
curva de demanda compara el precio de un
cierto bien con la cantidad de objetos
de ese bien que se vende bueno entonces
lo que vamos a hacer ahorita es cambiar
el precio de chocolate de 10 pesos a 20
pesos va entonces ahora el chocolate ya
ya cuesta 20 pesos entonces pues ahora
tenemos una cierta utilidad marginal por
precio distinta la utilidad marginal no
cambia o sea el chocolate nos sigue
gustando va entonces esto este térisse
paribus o sea vamos a cambiar únicamente
el precio de chocolate pensando que esto
no cambia nuestra preferencia por él ni
por lo de la fruta entonces ahora el
chocolate cuesta 20 pesos y como la
utilidad marginal sigue igual como se
duplicó el precio de la utilidad
marginal va a bajar a la mitad cuando la
utilidad marginal por precio vamos a
hacer la cuenta o sea ahora tendríamos
entre 20 aquí sería 5
aquí sería 80 dividido entre 20 x 4 60
entre 23 y 40 entre 20 es 2 entonces
ahora tenemos una menor utilidad
marginal de chocolate por el precio del
chocolate bueno entonces pensemos una
vez más que tenemos 50 pesos y queremos
gastar los de 10 en 10 10 10 10 10
entonces déjame ponerle me voy a poner
aquí de este lado voy a poner una vez
más que tenemos monedas de buenos
billetes monedas de 10 pesos entonces
otra vez tenemos aquí diez pesos diez
pesos diez pesos diez pesos y diez pesos
entonces ahora diez pesos no nos
alcanzan para una barra de chocolate
pero pensaremos que se puede comprar
media barra de chocolate va y que las
primeras dos barras de chocolate nos dan
este beneficio marginal va este esta
utilidad marginal por precios de 5 de
modo similar los kilos de frutas se
pueden vender por mitades y los primeros
2 kilos nos dan este beneficio marginal
los segundos 2 este de acá
y así sucesivamente vale bueno entonces
vamos a hacer las cuentas para ver qué
nos conviene entonces qué sucede con los
primeros diez pesos pues a ver ahora
este este primer chocolate o bueno este
primer medio chocolate sólo nos da cinco
pesos de utilidad marginal por precio
pero la fruta nos da seis entonces estos
primeros diez se van a gastar en fruta
sí entonces le voy a poner aquí que es
fruta
voy a ponerle fruta va y entonces es
fruta a una utilidad marginal por precio
de 6 va entonces aquí voy a poner qué
qué tipo de bien se compra y aquí le voy
a poner la utilidad marginal por precio
que tenemos bueno qué pasa con los
segundos 10 pesos pues otra vez ahora no
nos hemos acabado todo el kilo de fruta
verdad todavía otro medio kilo de fruta
lo seguimos prefiriendo a 120 o bien a
una utilidad marginal por precio de 6
que le gana a la del chocolate una vez
más la fruta sigue ganando volvemos a
comprar fruta a utilidad marginal de 6
los terceros diez pesos cambian verdad
bueno en realidad podríamos seguir
comprando fruta porque ahora son de a
cinco y a cinco de utilidad marginal por
precio pero pues para cambiarle tantito
y para hacerlo un poco más variado
pensemos que ahora es chocolate entonces
igual medio chocolate nos da una
utilidad marginal de por precio de 5
entonces aquí voy a poner que el
chocolate aquí bueno le voy a poner que
todos estos son medios va medio kilo de
fruta medio kilo de fruta media barra de
chocolate con una utilidad marginal de 5
luego podemos comprar otro chocolate
otra otra media barra de chocolate otra
vez a una utilidad marginal de 5 pero
con esto ya nos acabamos los chocolates
que podemos aguantar a una utilidad
marginal de 100 si a una utilidad
marginal por precio de 5 entonces aquí
ya dejamos de comprar chocolates y ahora
que seguimos comprando chocolates pues
no porque ahora la utilidad marginal por
precio nada más es de 4 comparado con
esta fruta que todavía podemos comprar a
una utilidad marginal por precio de 5
entonces hasta el final estos últimos 10
pesos los vamos a gastar en medio kilo
de fruta con una utilidad marginal por
precio de 5 muy bien entonces bueno aquí
aquí hay dos cosas interesantes número
uno podemos calcular la utilidad total y
vamos a hacer eso eso primero entonces
fíjate esta es la utilidad marginal por
precio es 6 pero gastamos 10 pesos
entonces aquí tenemos una utilidad este
marginal ya no por precio sino utilidad
de 60
aquí también de 60 nada más es
multiplicar por 10 50 50 50 estas son
las utilidades marginales y para obtener
la utilidad total nada más sumamos todos
estos números 60 y 60 son 120 50 y 50
son 100 que con los 120 dan 220 y con
estos 50 dan 270 esta es la utilidad
total eso es más o menos importante pero
lo que es más importante y lo que es lo
que nos interesa más en este vídeo es
qué pasó con la cantidad de chocolates
que se compraron ahora aquí se compraron
nada más dos medios chocolates es decir
ahora se compró solo un chocolate le voy
a poner por acá que compramos en total
en total compramos un chocolate y
compramos un kilo y medio verdad un kilo
y medio de frutas bueno lo interesante
es que pasamos de comprar tres
chocolates a pasar un chocolate a
comprar un chocolate si todo esto fuese
tenis paribus recuerda nada más cámara
cambiamos el precio del chocolate
pensando que todo lo demás el precio de
la fruta
la preferencia de los clientes cambiar
la preferencia cambiaría esta utilidad
marginal pero la preferencia estaba
igual todo quedaba constante pero
únicamente cambiando el precio
aumentando lo disminuyó la cantidad de
chocolates bueno entonces podemos hacer
una gráfica verdad para ver cómo como se
ve esto entonces ahora sí déjame hacer
un pequeño sketch de la gráfica de
demanda
aquí tenemos en este eje y en este eje
aquí tenemos precio en este lado tenemos
cantidad cantidad de chocolates
demandados entonces qué sucede qué pasa
cuando el chocolate costaba 10 y qué
pasa ahora que cuesta 20 cuando el
chocolate costaba 10 pesos
se demandaban tres unidades de chocolate
no voy a poner con este color naranja
entonces uno dos tres aquí se demandaban
tres unidades pero cuando el chocolate
ahora cuesta 20 pesos ya nada más se
demanda
una unidad una barra de chocolate
entonces aquí tenemos dos puntos de
nuestra gráfica de demanda entonces aquí
podemos unir la más o menos así la curva
de demanda se vería más o menos algo de
este estilo o bueno esta es una curva a
ver aquí está quedando como chiquita
pero si asumimos que la demanda es
lineal esto de aquí quedaría como una
línea recta algo más o menos como de
este estilo claro para saber realmente
cómo se ve la curva aquí en medio
tendríamos que hacer cambios de del
precio de chocolate un poco más
chiquitos o sea podemos pasar de 10
pesos a 10 pesos con 10 centavos 10
pesos con 20 centavos y así obtener
varios puntitos por acá que nos vayan
diciendo cómo se va moviendo esta curva